قالت المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق انها
استهدفت بطائره مسيره قاعده حرير
الامريكيه قرب مطار اربيل باقليم كردستان
شمال البلاد واكدت في بيان لها استمرارها
في مقاومه ما وصفتها بقوات الاحتلال
الامريكيه وان عملياتها تاتي ردا على
مجازر الكيان الصهيوني بحق قطاع غزه وفق
البيان في العاجل كما يظهر على شاشتنا
نقلا عن حركه حماس التي تدين باشد
العبارات العدوان الامريكي على العراق
وسوريا وتعتبره تصعيدا خطيرا وتعديا على
سياده
البلدين قال المتحدث باسم الحكومه
العراقيه باسم العوادي ان 16 شخصا بينهم
مدنيون لقوا مصرعهم واصيب
25 جراء القصف الامريكي على منطقتي عكاشات
قائم شرقي البلاد ووصف العوادي في بيان
الهجوم بعدوان جديد يستهدف سياده العراق
وقال ان الجانب الامريكي عمد بعد تنفيذه
الهجوم الى تزييف الحقائق عبر الاعلان عن
وجود تنسيق مسبق مع الحكومه العراقيه بهذا
الشان واعتبر البيان ان وجود التحالف
الدولي الذي خرج عن المهام الموكله اليه
والتفويض الممنوح له صار سببا لتهديد
الامن والاستقرار في العراق ومبررا لاقحه
في الصراعات الاقليميه والدوليه كما اكد
البيان ان اراضي العراق ليست ساحه لتصفيه
الحسابات وليست المكان المناسبه لارسال
الرسائل واستعراض القوه بين
المتخاصمين معنا من بغداد مراسل الجزيره
عبد الفتاح فايد اهلا بك عبد الفتاح ما
الذي حدده هذا البيان المتحدث باسم
الحكومه العراقيه بخصوص اجراءات بغداد في
الرد او التعامل مع هذا التصعيد
الامريكي نعم في الحقيقه البيان يعبر عن
غضب رسمي عراقي تجاه تلك الضربات
الامريكيه يمكن ان نلخص البيان بتلك
العبارات وايضا يحمل في الحقيقه تصعيدا في
لغه الخطاب العراقي تجاه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وربما ايضا تجاه المتخاصمين
معها في المنطقه هذا البيان في الحقيقه
ايضا يحمل في دلالاته وفي طياته في قراءه
اوليه له يحمل ربما
تماهيا واضحا بين الموقف الرسمي العراقي
وبين موقف فصائل المقاومه الاسلاميه في
العراق ربما فيما يتعلق بتلك الضربات وفي
الخسائر التي حققتها تلك ضربات هذا هذه
القراءات تاتي من قراءه البيان الصادر عن
الناطق باسم الحكومه العراقيه وايضا عن
الناطق باسم القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
العراقيه كلا البيانين اعتبر تلك الضربات
انتهاكا لسياده العراق اعتبرها ايضا
تقويضا لجهود الامن والاستقرار في العراق
وفي المنطقه بشكل عام وانها تجر العراق
وتجر المنطقه الى ما لا يحمد عقباه كما
قال اللواء يحيى رسول المتحدث باسم القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه العراقيه البيان
ايضا حمل انذارا يمكن القول من جانب
الحكومه العراقيه والقوات المسلحه
العراقيه للاطراف المتخاصمه بانها لن تسمح
العراق لن يسمح بان تكون ارضه ساحه لتصفيه
الحسابات وتبادل الرسائل بين المتخاصمين
اكد ايضا على ان الحكومه العراقيه سوف
تبذل جهودها للدفاع عن العراق وعن ارضه
ومدنه وابنائه في القوات المسلحه بكل
صنوفها وهي كلمه ايضا لها دلالات مهمه بكل
صنوفها هنا تعني بما في ذلك قوات الحشد
الشعبي التي تضم قوات من المقاومه وفصائل
المقاومه الاسلاميه العراقيه كما تسمي
نفسها لانها في ذات الوقت هي قوات نظاميه
قوات الحشد الشعبي هي قوات امنيه نظاميه ع
وبالتالي هي ستكون مستهجن ان تعرضت لاي
ضربات من جانب الحكومه العراقيه وايضا
ستكون الحكومه العراقيه مسؤوله عن التصدي
لتلك الهجمات ايضا كان من الرسائل المهمه
التي حملها بيان الناطق الرسمي باسم
الحكومه العراقيه الاشاره الى ان التحالف
الامريكي هنا عندما يقول التحالف الدولي
فهو يقصد التحالف الدولي الذي تاسس
لمواجهه داعش في او تنظيم الدوله في
العراق وفي سور هذا خرج عن مهامه الاصليه
واصبح يضر بامن المنطقه وامن العراق عبد
الفتاح فايد من بغداد شكرا جزيلا لك